tu te lundi politique avec vos gars le
dantec bonjour et le porte parole de la
république en marche
bonjour je suis bonjour à tous depuis qu
emmanuel macron a décidé de se lancer
dans la course à la présidentielle de
succès lancer son mouvement en marche
puis la république en marche a bien du
mal à se trouver des leaders réunion les
références se succèdent et le dernier en
date enrichi à 5 mois pas facile de
défendre ici politique décidée à paris
pas facile de se faire une place dans
une arène politique locale verrouillée
par les partis politiques de l'ancien
monde
pas facile de différencier les alliés
des adversaires et vous dire que
certains élus locaux ont intérêt à être
du côté du pouvoir à paris est du côté
du peuple à la réunion trois jeunes ont
créé à tête du mouvement farid monrovia
et des lignes référent il devait être
notre invité ce midi
mais c est victime d'une extinction de
voix charge des mat et stefano complète
un trio jusqu'à la porte parole et donc
la vie dès lundi politique sur la
première vous pouvez poser vos questions
à partir de 12h45 au 0262 99-2000
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation d'avoir remplacé farine
pas pu bien parce qu'il a plu voix
interchangeables en fait on travaille
véritablement avec une avec farid et
sharif en grande collaboration est on
on prend toutes les décisions à 3 donc
on avance à 3 vous étiez vous ce poste
de référent
oui j'avais déposé ma candidature pour
ce poste
après enfin comme on l'a déjà répété
c'est c'est une élection interne mais
qui donne les mêmes missions aux
référents et nous on est vraiment là
pour travailler en équipe et on
continuera à le faire campagne sur le
dépassement des idéologies le
dépassement de la division droite gauche
et dans la foulée des députés avaient
été élus par sophie si la réunion où ça
n'a pas pris à lens n'a pas réussi son
implantation ici pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché
en 2010 c'est pourquoi ça marche et
maintenant en 2017 quand on est arrivé
enfin il faut vendre à ne jamais oublier
que c'est un parti qui n'existaient pas
et qui n'avait après n'existe plus ici
enfin je dirais toujours que la
politique la réunion est assez
particulière où il faut un véritable
ancrage local
si vous ne partez pas d'une commune à la
réunion il est très compliqué de réussir
en politique
et donc quand vous allez vous y prendre
là nous sommes dans une véritable
structuration communal du mouvement ou
on est en train de faire ce qu'il faut
pour que dans toutes les communes de la
réunion il ya une base communale vous
savez pour l'instant à peu près combien
de divisions comme quand on force
alors aujourd'hui il ya mille huit cents
adhérents à la république en marche et
qui sont tous répartis sur une vingtaine
de comités et on est en train de faire
justement un très gros travail depuis
mercredi depuis que farid a été nommé
pour que toutes les communes va
renforcer et que nous soyons présents
véritable ans sur les 24 communes et
concrètement comment est ce qu'on fait
n'importe quoi
élargir le site il y aura une grosse
partie porte à porte du terrain pour
aller convaincre il y aura des ateliers
mais avant tout si on doit parler d'un
sujet aujourd'hui c'est le grand débat
national
le grand débat national auquel on invite
tous les réunionnais dans chaque ville
il ya des organisations qui se met en
place
il faut véritablement il participer
parce que c'est le moment on peut tout
dire on va parler de deux secondes sur
la situation des mouvements d'animaux
on a bien compris que l'humiliation
qu'elle quel rôle de paris quel rôle qu
est-ce qui s qui décide quoi finalement
en fait le ski le rôle à la réunion
c'est d'être véritablement un
porte-parole du gouvernement et des
mesures gouvernementales mais ça va
véritablement dans les deux sens où on
est les porte-paroles des réunionnais à
paris et on travaille en véritable
collaboration pour que les choses
avancent mais qui décide à paris 2 c'est
une discussion une décision collégiale
le bureau exécutif à paris qui qui suit
toute la politique nationale est des
gens qui ont éventuellement connaissent
la réunion sont venus ou comment ça va
ah oui il y en a
qui sont là qui visitent la réunion qui
sont en relation avec des élus
réunionnais et nous mêmes et par exemple
là vous avez ce week end une visite
ministérielle
le secrétaire d'état a remis à la table
vous êtes dans ce cas là quand une
visite ministérielle comme ça vous êtes
avertis vous êtes partie prenante du des
passants il ya toujours un moment
réservé pour les marcheurs et il y en
aura un là on y travaille vous traitez
le structurer un mouvement politique un
parti politique alors que depuis trois
mois
des jeunes sont dans la rue pour dire
que le système démocratique actuel ne
fonctionne pas qu'ils ne veulent plus
entendre parler des partis politiques
est ce que vous êtes à contre-courant
absolument pas je vais revenir sur le
grand débat national
c'est le moment qui est offert à tous
les français pour justement parler de
démocratie parler de fiscalité parlé de
tous les sujets qui les intéressent pour
le pays
on n'est pas là justement à faire mais
le dialogue ce qui dans le ce que ce
compte rendu ses clés les élus sont
considérés comme des gens qui sont
rompus
les partis politiques sont considérés
comme étant sclérosé et ne pouvant plus
représenter le peuple et les livres
qu'on peut être au peuple et qu est ce
que vous vous êtes contre courant de 2,2
cette tique
la confiance est clairement enfin
acclamant interrompu justement à cause
de toutes ces dérives et comment les
citoyens font confiance aux politiques
quand le politique tient ses engagements
quand le politique vient chez eux et ne
raconte pas n'importe quoi non on est
véritablement là pour construire on
on ne va pas faire du porte à porte pour
faire des promesses en fait du porte à
porte pour faire de la pédagogie c'est
ce que fait le gouvernement
c'est ce que ça apporte au quotidien aux
réunionnais et on n'est pas là pour
recommencer les erreurs du passé où les
élus viennent en période d'élection pour
faire des promesses et après ne tiennent
pas et pourtant il est arrivé des jacky
magné macro fassent des promesses qui
finalement sont pas tenues comment est
ce que vous êtes
il ya ya je parlerai jamais de promesses
non tenues il ya des engagements sont
encore on y travaille
après il ya des toujours des difficultés
on va dire administratives ou les choses
prennent du temps mais c'est le néant ce
ne sont jamais des des promesses qui ont
été mises à la poubelle sur le
fonctionnement même de deux anciens pour
revient dans sa critique et qui
compteront beaucoup beaucoup attendu en
vendée
est-ce que y est ce que pour vous il
faut faire un effort pour réconcilier
avec le système démocratique il faut
faire évoluer ce système il mettre plus
de démocratie participative plus de il
peut y avoir une part des deux il faut
que ceux qui viennent s'exprimer lors du
grand débat national dise clairement ce
qu'ils veulent parce que quand on est
élu on reçoit justement une délégation
on va dire de pouvoir des citoyens pour
exercer son mandat mais il faut le faire
justement quand les citoyens continuent
à avoir confiance en vous donc il faut
mettre en place les moyens de cette
confiance si demain dans le grand débat
national les citoyens demandent plus de
conseils citoyens dans les villes avant
que les grandes décisions soient prises
peut-être que ce sera une solution mais
le conseil consultatif cyril et c'est
toujours une bonne idée dans le sens où
on fait participer les citoyens
donc tout ce qui amène plus de
démocratie sera toujours favorables à la
démocratie dans l'organisation de deux
secondes marocaine fait
référence vous êtes vous en tant que la
marche conviviale organisée ou
simplement vous votre rôle
nous nous appelons les gens à y aller
pour donner leur avis après je peux vous
citer qu à titre personnel moi je serai
présent un grand débat ce samedi en tant
que citoyen mais aussi justement pour
peut-être quelques fois apporter des
réponses que les citoyens ne connaissent
pas comment ça s'organise pour l'instant
à la réunion ce grand débat c'est un peu
confus on a des matchs organisés par la
mairie il y en a qui sont labellisés
grand débat national
justement il y a
une plateforme qui a été mise en place
grand débat national pour toute la
france pour les outre-mer et c'est à
partir de cette plateforme là que les
personnes qui souhaitent organiser
récupère l'équipe d'organisation et
s'inscrivent pour organiser les grands
débats et après s'il ils ont une salle à
disposition il inscrivait également vous
comprenez l'exaspération de certains
citoyens mais aussi de certains élus on
entendu qui disent que les preuves de la
région sont guère connu depuis longtemps
que ça serait de nouveau la liste des
problèmes et les éventuelles solutions
ça sert que dormir un peu les gens je je
l'entends mais comme j'ai déjà dit vous
avez eu les assises des autres mais a
peut-être vous avez peut-être le livre
bleu généraux et idra mais aujourd'hui
le grand débat national va beaucoup plus
loin que ça on part sur le destin de la
france
on part sur des choses beaucoup plus
profondes comme la démocratie comme la
fiscalité nationale et on on peut
entendre que beaucoup de choses ont été
dites beaucoup de choses ont été écrites
mais il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
faire et c'est dans ce sens que le grand
débat national et est intéressant et en
même temps comme dirait manuel mâcon la
politique globale en discussion dans ce
groupe c est ce que ces patrons qui se
dépassent pas faire semblant de débattre
alors que vous faut les rangs d'une
politique les grandes orientations
économiques ne sont pas en question ont
toutes les questions sont ouvertes
après je rappellerai longtemps on voit
bien dans la façon dont les questions
sont formulés dans le grand débat qu'il
est question de deux de diminuer non
seulement les sages publie jamais de les
augmenter de 10 à pour jamais de
demander une vision
la politique et à ça je vous répondrais
qu'il ya eu une élection et que c'est
une élection qui a été démocratique mais
macron est élu sur un programme si il
n'a plus appliqué par le programme sur
lequel il avait été élu
il devrait aussi tous les électeurs qui
a eu donc on ne peut pas non plus faire
ce grand débat national sur tout un
programme politique
on est à mi mandat il ya des mesures qui
sont engagés on ne va pas débarrasser
enfin mettre un coup de pied sur la
table et pour te débarrasser donc il
n'est pas question de remettre en cause
la quelle est la politique générale du
gouvernement est ce que du coup la
question qui peuvent se faire de la
frustration je pense pas parce que on a
on a dit on l'a admis que peut-être la
méthode a été mauvaise peut-être que
certaines choses ont été faites avant
d'autres et c'est justement ça qui dans
la méthode a peut-être causé des
troubles des incompréhensions mais je
dirai toujours que pour le pays le
programme sur lequel emmanuel macron est
élu c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des résultats de ce
grand débat au final une nouvelle
politique il ya un
référendum qui est en discussion il n'y
a aucune décision se sont noyés je pense
oui que ce serait une bonne idée
justement pour sortir justement de cette
crise des gilet jaune par une solution
démocratique parce que le référendum
c'est démocratique le grand débat
national aujourd'hui il est ouvert à
tout le monde donc ce serait ce serait
une bonne option oui la colère contre m
il est assis là à justifier
vous savez il ya beaucoup plus
enfin ça fait beaucoup plus de deux ans
qui a des problèmes en france on est en
train de tout mettre sur le dos des
manuels macro mais c'est le résultat
aujourd'hui de 30 années de choses qui
n'ont pas été faites de faciliter
politique et quand il faut redresser le
navire
ben peut-être que ça peut froisser
certaines personnes est ce que c'est une
histoire de pédagogie aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup entendu le gouvernement ou le
président
il faut expliquer aux politiques est-ce
que y'a pas un risque là encore de
montrer la frustration de dire à des
gens mais c'est parce que vous avez pas
compris des gens qui eux sont à l'arrêt
parce que parce qu'ils ont un problème
devant moi parce que ils ont un problème
de devoir non enfin jeu
pour moi la pédagogie elle ira dans le
sens où à chaque fois quand on présente
une mesure du gouvernement
on l'apprend juste elle toute seule et
on ne l'analyse pas dans son ensemble
dans ce résultat d'ensemble pour le pays
je vais vous citer un exemple qui pour
moi est la plus grande mesure
qui était prise sous le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro à ce jour c'est les
divisions de classe pour les élèves
c'est que cette décision qui est une
décision qui a été prise et pour
laquelle on ne verra les vrais résultats
que dans plus de dix ans parce qu'on
verra une nouvelle génération qui peut
être est beaucoup plus épanouie beaucoup
plus à l'aise dans le travail
on entend déjà aujourd'hui que
l'éducation se passent mieux dans ces
classes là et la vision d' emmanuel
macron elle se projette pas sur un
quinquennat tout ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui c'est une vision à très long
terme pour les jeux qui n'est pas fiable
moi c'est ce mois qui sont pas finir 50
ha je je je l'entends bien c'est
c'est peut-être justement compliqué dans
ce sens là et mais il faut continuer à
expliquer peut-être que peut-être
justement là vous avez une urgence
aujourd'hui mais on voit aussi que
beaucoup justement dans la pédagogie ne
sont pas au courant que certaines z sont
à leur disposition et qui n'a et qui
n'en bénéficient pas alors on peut on
peut et on doit faire de la pédagogie
surtout à propos des aides sociales
vendredi lors d'une réunion avec les
élus et patrons des petites profession
philippe panis évoqué l'hypothèse d'une
mise en place de contreparties aux aides
sociales
est ce que c'est une une logique là
encore dans laquelle s'inscrivent les
maquereaux parce que vous savez déjà été
évoquée en est ce que est ce qu'on va
vers ça edouard philippe l'a bien
précisé d'une part c'est un avis
personnel et après l'arrosage personnel
dans la ministre hilare situé ça aussi
justement dans le cadre du grand débat
national où toutes les questions étaient
ouvertes
oui mais toutes les questions sont sur
la table c'est cette question demain
arrive il faudra aussi que les français
donnent leur opinion
donc c'est une question ouverte pour le
grand débat national et c'est une
question à laquelle vous répondriez
comment je n'ai pas d'avis sur cette
question c'est embêtant pour un
représentant politique
la voilà on je vous dis je n'ai pas
d'avis parce que justement c'est une
question qui en dans le cadre du grand
débat national
et si vous donner mon avis aujourd'hui
peut-être que c'est moi justement qui
brouilleraient les pistes du grand débat
national
mais ça veut dire que être aujourd'hui
à la tête d'un parti politique c'est
s'en remettre à l'avis général est pas
avoir de ligne politique
après le quand on parle des aides
sociales il faut tenir compte des
spécificités locales
la réunion est un pays qui socialement
est en difficulté il ne faut pas non
plus de l'autre côté que les gens aient
le sentiment qu'on les stigmatise pour
dire ce que j'ai déjà entendu que ça a
été annoncé pour dire justement que les
chemins ne foutent rien mais non je le
répète c'est une idée si elle n'est pas
validé elle ne sera pas mise en oeuvre à
quelle quel levier
faudrait-il actionner selon vous ou pour
créer plus d'emplois et nous on sait que
c'est la question des aides sociales et
du chômage et sur la question des années
sont pas cons qu'on peut créer ce qu'il
faut continuer à aider les entreprises
telles que ça été fait jusqu'à
maintenant
avec quels résultats faut-il mettre plus
de garde-fous est-ce qu'il faut
continuer avec la logique du 6e à mon
sens il faut continuer à aider les
entreprises parce que ce sont les
créatrices d'emplois on ne peut pas
aller à l'encontre de ça on ne pourra
pas prouver le contraire
mais comme vous le dites il faut
véritablement contrôler ce qu'on donne
aux entreprises pour veiller justement
que derrière il n'y ait pas d'abus parce
que certains en abusent
ce n'est pas du tout la grande majorité
mais certains vont profiter des systèmes
pour justement au lieu de créer de
l'emploi faire plus de profit ni à leurs
bénéfices bien qu'on pourrait imaginer
exigé de la part de l'entreprise de
créer l'emploi je ne pense pas que ce
soit légal jeu
on ne peut pas exiger d'une entreprise
qu'elle crée de l'emploi mais il ya des
mécanismes de surveillance qui peuvent
être mises en place
quels souvenirs la politique
politicienne parce que ça fait aussi
partie bien sûr de votre quels sont vos
alliés politiques arrêtent alors
aujourd'hui nous on est véritablement
ouvert à tous les partis politiques à
tous ceux qui veulent faire avancer la
réunion et faire avancer la république
en marche
il a déjà été dit que le moment des
européennes sera un véritable moment de
clarification pour nous parce que on
verra qui est avec nous et qui ne l'est
pas ceux qui sont là et vous sortez vous
pas forcément parce que on n'est pas
dans une logique d'opposition puisque
les oppositions à mon sens sont toujours
stérile
il faut véritablement continuer à
travailler ceux qui veulent travailler
avec nous la pente et ouverts en même
temps les européennes ça va pas
tellement ce joyau parce que aussi bien
plus de liste il ya plus de lister les
listes se sont améliorées de campagne
non loin de voir des élus qui vont se
prononcer il y aura voilà il y aura des
élus qui vont se positionner donc liste
la liste est pas encore décidé donc on
verra au moment de la parution la liste
nous avait pas deux pistes non et pas
dans vie non plus à titre personnel non
les personnes de votre entourage
à ma connaissance non un peu du mal à
s'y retrouver dans la région où ce sont
les amis de thierry robert qui ont été
validés depuis paris comme étant
la république en marche au sein du
conseil régional est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas on est parti sur un
nouveau référent une nouvelle
organisation
il ya des discussions qui sont à mes
temps avec les adhérents qu'avec les
élus et on continuera justement cette
clarification pour justement de bien
mettre en place les choses et savoir ben
kg de bois en question l'idée c'est
d'avoir des élus engagés la république
qui sont à véritablement la réplique en
revanche on a demandé justement via le
nouveau référent pour justement
connaître le fonctionnement parce que on
a eu plusieurs mois sans référent sens
justement discussions politiques donc en
sachant que comme on l'a répété certains
font la politique selon le sens du vent
on a besoin c'est à dire ça veut dire
quoi
selon les sondages m c'était vous pensez
à qui je n'ai pas de nom à vous dire là
mais il y en a il y en a quelques-uns il
y en a d'autres qui ce qu'ils ont
montrée justement l'europe mais on sens
est incertaine général parce que c'est
un climat général justement qu'on a
senti et nous dans notre groupe on a
besoin de clarifications pour savoir
avec qui avance est trop vieux ou aux
élus au conseil c'est pareil qui a
décidé qu'ils étaient âgés qu'ils
l'étaient pas on peut supposer que dans
ces personnalités en marche
il ya un michel à nous qui nous concerne
c'est que vous avez besoin
la manche a besoin d'un sénateur aussi
on marche à paris c'est con ça se décide
on a on a clairement besoin d'avoir
des représentants qu'ils soient plus
souvent que nous à paris ça c'est une
évidence et on a on a aujourd'hui le
soutien du sénateur qui a été
essentielle on a un peu le sentiment si
je peux me permettre que ce qu'on a on
assiste là la petite quoi l'ancien quand
même avec des accords et des alliances
n'ont pas grand chose à voir et les
convictions politiques
aujourd'hui avec le
ce qui était mis en place on a
véritablement un préfet politique c'est
à dire ça fait peur c'est un préfet
politique c'est non ça ne me fait pas
peur ça veut simplement rappelé que
justement il ya une telle politique qui
qui va justement orienter les choses à
la réunion ça veut dire deux savent bien
que c'est aujourd'hui qu'il va marcher
ça va pas être une décision autoritaire
dans le sang c'est justement de l'autre
côté du mot mais ça va être une décision
collégiale où on va justement de pouvoir
discuter et savoir justement où se
positionne chacun mais je n'ai pas de
doute sur l'engagement du sénateur
denman et didier robert lui et il le
maquereau compatible car la sueur vous
avez avec lui ça va on répétera même si
vous d'accord mais on continuera à dire
qu'on est ouvert à tous ceux qui vont
travailler pour la réunion c'est
d'accord c'est un message qui est
souvent entendu je vous l'accordé mais
en ait trois jeunes là qui sommes
véritablement motivé à faire bouger les
choses pour la république en marche et
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec la
politique régionale est parti il ya
certaines choses avec lesquelles je suis
en accord peut-être d'autres moins c'est
moi je ne parle pas je prends pas de
justement de clivage où tout une
personne est mauvaise ou tu te casses
année bonne fin il ya des choses qui
sont très bien pour la réunion d'autres
- enfin je je je pourrai pas les citer
si demain si demain didier robert se
présenter de nouveau à région est ce que
vous ouvriez des motifs de présenter une
liste opposée aujourd'hui on n'est pas
sur ce sujet là parce qu'on est
véritablement dans la structuration
du mouvement si je vous parlais des
régionales aujourd'hui ce serait trop
m'avancer et trop présomptueux on est en
train de construire le mouvement faisons
déjà ce qu'on a à faire aujourd'hui au
niveau communal voyons ce que nous
valons au niveau communal et après on
continuera à avancer
vous avez pas merci aux gars et plus ou
moins proche des 1000 euros
je ne sais pas et gilbert annette ça va
être la même réponse on verra peut-être
parce que gilbert annette et thierry
gaubert est organisée à comprendre la
campagne en 2017 il est des plus
qu'engagé donc ces gens là aujourd'hui
enfin moi à titre personnel enfin je
peux très bien discuter avec tous après
il faut qu'on s'accorde politiquement
sur ce qui à faire ce qui n'a pas faire
ce qui est comme on avance mais on verra
justement au moment de ces européennes
comme j'ai déjà dit qu'ils s'engagent
véritablement à nos côtés ça veut dire
que c'est ce sont ces personnalités
politiques se disent heureux gilbert
annette qui vont devoir faire la
démarche d'aller voir où est ce que
c'est vous qui allez un moment fait le
tour des élus des personnalités
politiques qui pourraient vous semblez
plus ou moins proche et calais entamé
des négociations avec marchal cuisine ça
peut ça peut aller dans les deux sens
parce que
on le dit aujourd'hui on est un parti
politique on va pas les attendre tout le
monde va parler non plus
appelé tout le monde mais on est un
parti politique on s'affirme comme tel
ceux qui veulent travailler avec nous
peuvent nous contacter peut-être que
certains ont les contactera directement
à propos de contacteur je rappelle aux
auditeurs que partir de d'autres me
poser des questions à notre invité c'est
à partir de 45 02 72 99 2000 stéphane
revello qui donc la tête de la
république en marche à la réunion avec
mon regard
quelle stratégie pour les prochaines
élections vous disiez pour les
européennes ça va être important
même si la réunion c'est que c'est
compliqué et si l'on pourra écouter et
après on va surtout donner 20 toutes les
clés aux citoyens pour bien comprendre
l'intérêt de de ce que la prod ce
qu'apporte l'europe à la réunion
l'europe c'est des milliards pour la
réunion il faut justement s'y intéresser
pour qu après derrière on puisse suivre
tout ça et faire véritablement avancer
la réunion avec les fonds européens
les élections suivantes ce sont donc les
mini cheval 2020 certains sont déjà dans
le bon sens mais ça que ça démarre déjà
ça va être un moment important ce que
c'est là que vous allez voir si vous
avez réussi votre implantation vous
votre objectif alors là on est parti sur
une structuration en comités locaux donc
un comité local par ville mais ce n'est
pas parce qu'une personne sera
responsable d'un comité local que sera
automatiquement une personne candidate
aux municipales
ça va être le travail de terrain qui va
montrer qui
maki est capable d'y aller qui ne
connaît pas on va aller tout de suite au
sens large c'est quelqu'un qui nous
appellent c'est pascal qui nous
appellent de ce le bon jour on vous
écoute
oui en fait ma femme a fait réagir tout
à l'heure quand j'ai entendu votre
invité dire que monsieur maquereau a été
élu sur un programme
je trouve ça assez agaçant parce que les
c'est en partie faux je dirais parce que
il faut rappeler que il ya eu un grand
nombre d'abstentions que les votes
blancs ne sont pas pris en compte et que
beaucoup de gens vont voter contre
marine le pen est pas pour monsieur
mâcon donc voila merci merci pour votre
question pascal stéphane revello vous
vous réponds vous entendez 7 cette
remarque est un accro certes a été élu
mais peut-être pas sur son droit je
l'entends et je vais déjà beaucoup
entendu
après on a un système démocratique qui
est ce qu'il est
une élection a donné emmanuel macron
président la république
on revient toujours aux sujets
essentiels du moment le grand débat
national
si demain il ya une majorité de français
qui arrivent dans le grand débat
national pour demander une modification
des élections peut-être que ce sera pris
un coup selon le nombre de français qui
et demandera nous avons vincent qui nous
appellent de la possession bonjour
vincent décor marche je déjà cité
courage lorsque tu es quand même
difficile de représenter la avec des
grands marche à la réunion et la
question est est ce que tu es pas
justement suicidaire comme stratège
politique de représenter le parti des
manuels wagon je rappelle que tous les
week-ends et des milliers de francs des
titres ea mâcon dérision la production
même à l'arrivée
et est ce que vous vous solidariser en
totalité des propositions de manuel
macron je pense notamment à vos
contrepartie pour les minima sociaux
1ère civ rémunération est ce que vous
avez et même positionnement là pour la
réunion on a fait merci à vous vincent
sur les minima sociaux
c'est une pop aux maquereaux on n'y a
répondu cela sur des minorations je le
je vais le dire aussi
ce n'est pas non plus une proposition d'
emmanuel macron c'est un maître réunion
qu'il a proposé dix ans que dans la
réponse ce jour là ce soir du grand
débat ça semblait pas très improvisés
j'étais pareil
mâcon qui a mis son tapis l'idée de san
jose 10 ans mais ça mais sa réponse
c'est aussi que c'était à nous de
décider nous de voir la réunion sur le
tapis c'est pas tous les sujets tous les
sujets peuvent être discutés quand c'est
quand on discute après qu'on trouve les
solutions et je vais revenir sur la
première question de notre éditeur csu
sont politiques
si aujourd'hui les citoyens ont pas
confiance dans la politique c'est parce
que justement il voit des gens qui ne
tiennent pas leurs engagements et kin
two qui ne tiennent pas leurs promesses
je suis engagé auprès d'emmanuel mac
ronde depuis les premiers jours si
demain je changeais jallet à droite à
gauche
ce serait complètement incohérent et ça
donnerait justement encore plus raison
citoyens ne pas faire confiance aux
politiques nous avons journée du port
avec nous aujourd'hui au virus
monsieur être venue des gages aux élus
démocratiquement
alan démocratiquement il faut être
visionnaire voit ça veut dire sur le
plan intelligent avec 31 ans
vous devez l'argent aussi comme patron
maintenant mon idée c'est une remarque
en forme de question
vous n'êtes pas en place déjà et vous
qu'en pensez vous parce que vraiment
c'est la politique
la poésie de votre chat flat mouvant
aujourd'hui exactement 1 0
maintenant je pouvoir d'achat sans gros
problème les boues 40 ans noah renault
on essaye de régler sa personne
maintenant si nous complice riches non
oui madame des gens d'église dépenses à
accueillir la balpa menace pas menacée
ou plus un jour n'est pas la seule à
l'antenne
d'accord d'accord mais s'il ya un grand
débat organisé au port jean rené vous
aurez peut-être l'occasion de rencontrer
ses fans de vélo me vous entendez 7
il ya de la colère il ya le dia de là il
ya bien presque parfait quand on parle
des macros en ce moment vous l'entendez
mais oui je l'entends vous avez enfin je
je suis réunionnais je suis né j'ai
grandi à la réunion les problèmes de la
réunion ne me sont pas inconnus
monsieur parler d'argent je suis pas
issu d'une famille riche je sais ce que
c'est que ne pas avoir d'argent et c'est
je sais entendre ce genre de discours et
la colère qui couve derrière mais après
il parlait de légitimité encore une fois
je leur dis si demain le système
démocratique doit évoluer c'est via le
le référendum peut-être via le grand
débat national
mais on ne peut pas parce qu'on n'est
pas d'accord
remettre en cause l'élection d'un
président de la république la question
du pouvoir d'achat est centrale en
première et pour l'instant la réponse ni
libre pour moi oui c'est le pouvoir
d'effacer un véritable sujet essentiel
qu'il faut régler en urgence
on a eu la visite du délégué à la
concurrence il ya quelques jours
[Musique]
je n'ai pas beaucoup entendu c'est vrai
mais je pense qu'il a beaucoup travaillé
c'est pas parce qu'on est sur les
plateaux télé qu'on travaille plus que
quand on est dans les murs aux dents
mais il a été sur les plateaux télé il y
aura 12 on peut pas annoncer avant que
le travail soit fait là il ya encore
justement l'appel à candidature a été
lancé pour la participation de 50
réunionnais aux travaux justement de
l'observatoire
il faut que les réunionnais se
saisissent de ce sujet et je pense
qu'après cette période là on pourra et
je l'espère on pourra arrêter de dire
que les prix ne sont pas transparents
journée a évoqué aussi le le climat
entre pendant les manifestations aussi
quelques échos quel regard vous pouvez
partir sur cette actualité c'est ça
c'est triste de voir qu'il ya les
violences continuent
presque qu'on aujourd'hui noms
retiennent que les violences parce que
moi je respecte toutes les
manifestations le sens des événements
aujourd'hui n'est plus celui d'origine
on est plus sur des revendications de
fond on est sûr de la colère de la haine
ça devient très vite ça devient physique
quand on a quand on voit un véhicule de
police se fait caillasser on ait pu
justement dans la démocratie et la
république le respect de tout ce qui va
avec
et de l'autre côté le nombre de deux
manifestants blessés par des tirs de
départ des des situations
d'affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre qui sont crise y est parvenu
quoi ce que vous allez les
c'est clair que les incidents sont
regrettables après pour chaque incident
il ya des enquêtes
il faut laisser la justice faire son
travail les jeunes diront que la justice
n'est pas indépendante mais si elle est
indépendante de notre pays on reste une
démocratie et la justice 30 avait on
entendu vous vous l'avez expliqué que le
travail de c'était aussi de faire
remonter à paris la réalité locale park
parc elle par un tuyau quand ça marche
il ya beaucoup de possibilités nous en
tant que équipes départementales de la
république en marche on est en contact
avec le mouvement
après on est aussi en contact avec les
conseillers
lisez donc on peut discuter on peut
transmettre des messages
ils sont demandeurs ils sont demandeurs
à paris de comprendre la situation
ah oui
moi je suis en contact assez régulier
avec le conseiller de l'elysée de passer
outre mer et il est demandeur se sont
pas des gens qui sont fermés comme on
dit dans leur tour naulleau tour
d'ivoire ce sont vraiment des gens qui
viennent prendre l'information au
terrain pour trouver les solutions et on
a un président de la république est
engagée à trouver des solutions on à
monsieur olivier pon bonjour à une
question simple le premier dialyse et je
les tweets ou si cette vie les vétérans
où quelques-uns qui échangent sur leur
maillot est-ce qu il pas possible de
séparer le politique de la mecque sera
dit c'est bon alors les chaînes et
craintif et que les politiques ne vont
pas à entrer dans ce jeu là c'est une
bonne question qui peut justement entrer
dans le cadre du grand débat pour le
cadet à refonder la démocratie parce que
cette question là c'est je pense que
c'est aussi nier peut-être dans la
pensée de monsieur aux emplois
le copinage ou éviter les roches
politique et c'est ça l'idée je pense
que si je pense que voilà je pense que
ça ne s'adresse pas merci c'est une
bonne question il faut il faut mettre
cette question là sur la table après
comme j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure quand
on fait une élection c'est aussi pour
déléguer certains pouvoirs et si on ne
délègue pas ce pouvoir de décision
quelque sorte ça voudrait dire que tout
le monde devrait se réunir tout le temps
pour décider de ce que la commune de
faire oui mais je lui fait d'accord avec
vous merci merci monsieur on arrive en
toute fin d'émission
juste un dernier mot la direction de la
république rend marche n'est pas pour
l'instant grand paritaire c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire trois garçons trois
jeunes garçons
il ya des jeunes
fille qui inquiétait déjà là qu'ils
n'avaient pas pu nous rejoindre samedi
c'était sofia ferrer voilà on en sera
trois hommes trois femmes c'est ça
l'objectif
à quelle échéance ça peut se faire dès
la semaine prochaine et donc il y aura
un référent il sent que quoi en fait on
est quoi cette organisation diablement
en équipe soudée donc les
on discute tous les jours on prend les
décisions sans tous les jours donc il ya
ya aucune difficulté à travailler
ensemble
merci beaucoup stéphane randrianarivelo
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui je
rappelle que vous faites partie donc de
cette direction locale de la république
en marche sur ses revenus et que free
mongolia qui est le référent n'était pas
aujourd'hui pour cause d'extinction de
voix que vous avez vous pensé à vous
demain à cette heure là ce sera le coeur
de la presse et vous construisez ou
rénover votre logement vous voulez une
maison économe en énergie où il fait bon
vivre
les conseillers info énergie vous donne
tous les conseils et vous accompagne
pour améliorer le confort thermique de
votre maison dit au revoir à la chaleur
de l'été et contacter les conseillers
info énergie au 02 62 250 7 257 prix
d'un appel local
les yeux sont animés par la fp l'énergie
réunion est financé par la région
réunion et l'ademe
[Musique]
drôlement bien camille ça va
voici la bat elena drôlement bien tell
me savard rôle montceau kalaba des potes
à moi et ça pas bon à la moindre est dit
on des bâtiments est savamment à la
moindre et 10 ans allemand souffre ici
ça va
mouzon forte les la donne au smic ni ça
va rue des bouchers pour bana
mon papa
pour manger local sabah
ferme à l'oeil à mon papa
à mont moïse ok ça va
[Musique]
non
donne mondiaux ce qui s'en va battre la
tnt banales tellement violent me savard
roman soigner son bazar
en cuisine au bois légal
à aix enfin fallait pas là
38,6 ne vois les gars
à elle son papa n'est pas là
le monde
[Musique]
c'est d'écouter la première dans
quelques instants 13h les titres de
france info et puis à 6000 diaz au tce
pas madonna c'est un petit bisou nous
respectent une tradition à l'espace et
aime la vie pour le meilleur et le pire
poursuivre bonjour j'ai six jours tous
les poissons nouvel album ouais hein de
monsieur mais pas le meilleur depuis
annoncé par l album 1 le nouvel album
c'est tout ce qui est là voilà le médium
non mais c'est la droite en fait le
titre de l'album c'est dernières
volontés à niveau l'an dernier volonté
est là vous avez reconnu mais suppose
que oui monsieur jacky ce gros matou les
la haye midi avec nous c'est super moi
j'adore regarder et à la la et puis
leurs magnifiques chansons qu'on a
écouté ce matin aussi avec jacky s'était
il me semble un autre voilà et j'espère
avoir la version sata près la scène un
petit coup de téléphone tout à l'heure
un petit bonjour sur la première chez
sonia pour vous accompagner dans
quelques instants qui ont voyagé aussi
également avec anne bono oui c'est sûr
instantanée du monde
merci nous écouter bon après midi à tous
il est 13 heures jean michel blanquer
prudent sur la proposition de loi de
sanctionner l'antisionisme le ministre
de l'éducation est revenu ce matin sur
france info sur cette idée lancée par
plusieurs députés
pour lui il faut ton discuter cette
proposition doit lancer après les
insultes proférées contre le philosophe
alain finkielkraut samedi en marge d'une
manifestation des gilet jaune à paris le
grand débat s'invite à l'hôpital des
discussions se tiennent aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital paul brousse de villejuif en
région parisienne
plusieurs débats seront organisés tout
au long de la semaine dans d'autres
hôpitaux
le but est de permettre aux
professionnels de santé d'apporter leur
contribution au grand débat national
il tente de sauver l'usiné ford de
blanquefort en gironde le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire
l'intersyndicale et les élus locaux se
réunissent aujourd'hui
objectif trouver des clients ou seul
repreneur déclaré du site la société
punchs les syndicalistes demandent à
l'état de faire pression sur les
constructeurs
une réunion aujourd'hui des ministres
des affaires étrangères européens au
coeur des discussions la syrie et
notamment la question du retour des
ressortissants partis combattre avec le
groupe etat islamique à donald trump a
demandé hier aux européens de les
rapatrier
le président américain menace de les
libérer ont joué hier la suite de la 25e
journée de ligue 1 de football le psg a
battu saint-etienne 1-0 une victoire
grâce à un but de killian mba p bordeaux
a battu toulouse 2 buts à 1 0 0 entre
caen et strasbourg et lille montpellier
france info la première
[Musique]
sonia sur la première
et vous le canapé terroir et non maja
qui le chassera sur l'antenne thaler ah
bah oui notre île une île à grand
spectacle
voilà bah c'est aujourd'hui ça a
commencé puis vous le savez notre rendez
vous pour la deuxième heure c'est avec
jacky le chat cet après midi entre 14 et
15 mai vous le savez aussi vous pouvez
m'appeler à partir de 13h30
parce qu'après ça entre 14 et 15 de la
pulpe en cause et donc le mieux c'est
d'appeler bien avant d'accord tout de
suite je vous propose l'histoire de
l'océan indien
l'histoire l'océan de tous les rêves
avec daniel vaxelaire
[Musique]
bon la semaine dernière on a fait le
tour de l'océan indien on a déterminé un
petit peu ses frontières et maintenant
vous allez me dire mais quel temps il
fait dans l'océan indien
eh bien il fait plutôt bon il fait
plutôt chaud parce que c'est un océan
entièrement tropicale
c'est assez simple à expliquer puisque
il est fermé des deux côtés par des
blocs continentaux et donc les eaux de
l'océan indien circulent à l'intérieur
de cette au cern
alors si on se penche sur la carte on
s'aperçoit que le tropique du cancer le
tropique nord passe pratiquement au nord
de l'océan indien puisque il
ils passent dans la partie nord de
lascars en ferme
une bonne partie des eaux de l'océan
indien donc mr tropicale mers chaudes
mère dans laquelle on va trouver
beaucoup de récifs coralliens très peu
d'alcool comme dans le pacifique
beaucoup de barrière corallienne
beaucoup de lagon enfermés dans des
barrières
par exemple celui de mayotte qui est un
des plus beaux lagons du monde mais
quand on a dit que ces indiens et c'est
une mer chaude
on n'a pas tout dit parce que au milieu
de cet océan il y a une frontière
invisible qui est l'équateur et le
climat au nord de l'équateur n'est pas
le même que celui au sud de l'équateur
quand c'est l'été au nord c'est l'hiver
au sud
on aura donc deux systèmes climatiques
différents avec des phénomènes un petit
peu parallèle par exemple on aura des
cyclones qui vont se former au nord de
l'équateur qui tourne dans le sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre et
des cyclones qui vont se former au sud
de l'équateur six mois plus tard et qui
vont tourner dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre
donc vous voyez déjà la frontière qui va
empêcher à certains moments la
circulation d'une partie de l'océan
indien à l'autre ça ça va être
déterminant pour la navigation
température moyenne de cet océan indien
relativement élevée puisqu'elle ne
descend jamais en dessous de 20 degrés
en hiver
bien sûr dans la zone intertropicale
parce que si vous aller plus au sud sur
le 45e par exemple elle tombe à 10
degrés voilà et on parlera demain des
phénomènes de vent et de courants bien
sûr qui sont induits
par ce système climatique là demain
[Musique]
voilà la suite de l'histoire de l'océan
indien demain à la même heure avec
daniel vaxelaire sur la première la
météo avec vers l'est au spécialiste de
l'assainissement individuel et de la
récupération d'eau de pluie
www.valeo.com peu de nuages pour cet
après midi surtout dans les eaux avec
des averses plus fréquentes et
localement soutenues de trois bassins au
tampon avec un coup de tonnerre possible
ailleurs et bien les précipitations sont
plus éparses
la chaleur est de plus en plus présentes
sur le littoral ou plus chaud de ce
lundi le thermomètre grimpe jusqu'à 33
degrés sur le littoral ouest 26 à 28
environ dans les cirques et 18 à 20 au
pas de bellecombe et au maïdo un vent de
nord-est qui est bienvenu un vigoureux
d'ailleurs au nord de la pointe des
aigrettes jusqu'à la grande chaloupe
mais aussi de sainte-rose à
saint-philippe avec des rafales voisines
de 60 kilomètres heure ce vent est
également sensible à la plaine des
cafres ainsi qu au maïdo et au volcan
les brise prédomine vers saint pierre la
météo avec vers l'est au spécialiste de
l'assainissement individuel et de la
récupération d'eau de pluie
www.valeo.com présent place à anne bono
pour instantanée du monde aujourd'hui
elle nous entraîne en inde à gujarat
dans le désert de coach asura bonne
écoute instantanée du monde
abdullah il y a tout ici tout ce qu'il
faut pour vivre une boutique de thé un
tailleur un barbier un bazar minuscule
et une échoppe qui laisse voler les
guirlandes de shampooing en petite
pochette individuel dans le vent fort du
désert du coach
avant qui se fraie un chemin entre les
ruelles de sable se faufile entre les
maisons de ciment basses faisant claquer
les fils électriques striant le ciel
gris entre les habitations poudre et de
poussières s'épuise quelques rares
acacias les épines orné de sacs
plastiques
il y a tout ici un temps plein en face
de la mosquée dans ce petit village de
l'inde de l'ouest flirtant avec le
pakistan à la frontière du grand désert
séparant les deux pays
les voiles des femmes bat dans l'air qui
jamais ne s'apaise à la mesure des sons
sortant des dizaines d'ateliers aux
portes grandes ouvertes
[Musique]
et
c'est un travail qu'on fait de
génération en génération
j'ai appris de mon père j'ai commencé ce
travail quand j'avais 10 ans et
maintenant j'ai quel âge déjà 65 ans non
j'ai 75 ans il ne cessa picciotto j'ai
75 ans oui pourrait avoir 75 ans haji
ali mahmoud suleiman le cheveu dru et
blanc la barbe tout aussi immaculée
cachant un visage buriné laissant
s'échapper un sourire généreux aux yeux
malicieux
l'homme vêtu de blanc est assis par
terre sur un sac de jute dans la lumière
se déversant de la porte grande ouverte
et d'une fenêtre sans vitres aux grilles
métalliques autour de lui sa mancelle un
bric à brac de ferraille que deux
employés s'échine tabac très ali mais en
les coûts aux ateliers alentours 20
bébés
il ya d'autres familles aussi qui font
ça il ya des à rizhao
il ya des sous marins mais c'est moi qui
ai appris à tout le monde
il
des cloches le village de dura résonne
au temps du fair batik des cloches qui
naissent dans ses ateliers
les notes dispersent et fissa dans les
étendues désertiques aux alentours de la
ferraille et du vent qui deviennent sous
les doigts du maître des articles
essentiels en ces contrées du métal de
l'air et un savoir-faire que le vieil
homme se régale à vous faire partager
davantage au travail de la terre
il travaille le métal tout le travail de
la terre c'est les femmes à qui s'en
occupe c'est elle qui va vous le montrer
tout le travail de la forge
c'est le travail des hommes à la forge
c'est moi on sait lui une autre qui
travaillent ce sont les hommes qui
s'occupent de 5 à l'arrière de l'atelier
s'ouvre une cour là j'habitais par les
femmes de la maison et par un bélier
attachés par une corde devant la véranda
les filles passent sans arrêt qui le
pose sur la hanche qui le bois sur la
tête qui le linge et les nattes à
secouer fatima ben la maîtresse de
maison semble solide et pragmatique
distribuant les ordres et s'attelant au
travail de la terre sans un sourire de
la terre d'où naissent les cloches les
cheveux longs colorés aux aînés
s'échappant de son voile de coton anta
ndiaye la robe longue date dans les
mêmes motifs
elle s'assied sur une natte et ce fait
apporter l'eau la terre et des bourgs de
coton à la l1 j'utilise de l'eau boueuse
de l'eau avec de la terre je vais
mélanger cette terre avec du coton
malades
après il faudra bien mélanger le coton
avec de la terre comme ça le mélanger
avec un pilon ont le malaxer ensuite on
fait des galets des galettes comme pour
manger on va recouvrir la cloche avec
cette mascarade
fatima rôle ces galettes de terre brune
et fibreuses le vent de temps à autre un
oeil sur les travaux de ses quatre
filles dans la cour la plus jeune a 13
ans pour elle l'école est terminée à
15km de duras on estime que l'école
secondaire est trop éloignée pour y
envoyer des jeunes filles
les cloches sont apportés l'oeil
néophyte pourrait les croire achevé des
cloches de faire toute simple de taille
diverse et encore muette ont 30 d'abord
la cloche dans cette boue et on la
tourne cette pègre et ensuite on la
recouvre avec cette galette de terre
cette poudre c'est un mélange de cuivre
et un autres alliages au mix apparaît
évident ça sert à décaper le faire alors
le biba couleur a bien sûr la cloche
[Musique]
rod quand on fait ça tous les jours
pour nous c'est difficile parce que vous
savez on commence à travailler et rien
un enfant qui se met à pleurer alors on
doit se laver les mains pour aller
s'occuper de l'enfant et après on
reprend un travail et c'est comme ça
toute la journée on s'occupe de tout que
faire c'est notre travail non enroulant
son foulard sur sa nuque
fatima bay nous dévoile une large boucle
en haut recouvrant de filigranes quitte
son oreille au dessus de la cour le ciel
gris ne laisse pas tomber une goutte de
pluie la mousson est chiche dans le
catch en tassant le linge dans des
bassines métallique elle commande aux
filles de l'eau qu'elle ne tire pas la
citerne de la cour mais quel sens vont
chercher au dehors leurs pieds nus font
soulevé des nuages de poussière grise
tandis qu'elle passe la large porte
métallique ouvrant sur les ruelles
[Musique]
la violence
dans un coin de la cour qu'elle ça m'a
mis en route la soufflerie électrique
faisant passer au rouge et la poignée de
charbon de bois qu'il a animée c'est ici
que les cloches sont cuites